and the lefty-hitter jazz chisholm
junior
defensive alignment but no need it's a
strikeout one way
nice little cutter right off the outside
corner very polite ovation for starling
martay
his first game back as an opponent
there you got him anderson takes care of
marte back-to-back strikeouts
[Applause]
in the air to shallow center long run
but plenty of time to get under it for
reynolds and a one two three top the
first for tyler anderson good start to
the
home stand and home fans gonna get a
chance to see key brian hayes
and that brings up key brian hayes
thursday april the 1st
launched a home run of the left field
wall it was the next day in his first
at-bat that he got hurt that left wrist
a ground ball
diving stop by chism to his feet throw
to first
not in time infield hit how about that
his first
at bat back place no time
base hit very seldom do you see him
hanging there
there's a shot into right field key
brian hayes will motor to third
and it's first and third and
one away in the pirates first inning
[Applause]
there's a perfect pitch inside corner
for a big
out number two
eighth pitch of the at-bat is a called
strike three
don't even need the caught stealing
hernandez gets a couple of k's in the
first and leaves two on
top of the second coming up when boston
got
rained out they just came from buffalo
where the blue jays now reside
here's the pitch crack bat comebacker
and on to first
anderson cooper and that's one out
high pop shallow left
short stop could be called off by gamel
newman went out but gamal
properly puts it away two outs
one two three first he's got the first
two outs in the second
and he has a one two three second inning
with three strikeouts
[Music]
and this is a very easy conversation to
have because the starting staff has been
outstanding this year
the bullpen has been outstanding this
year i fly into center field
out number two
lowest strikeout rate in baseball second
lowest
walk and it doesn't instead it's a great
play in center
on the sinking line drive starling marte
makes the sliding play
scoreless after two
a gallon away here's the pitch we gotta
swing in the ground ball towards second
base frazier in front of it has it
and onto first for the out one away
and birdie out toward left field that
will fall for a
base hit so he's got to be one guy that
joins the party that's right
doesn't as it were hernandez gets the
bunt down
anderson gets the ball over to first and
the sacrifice goes
one to four runner into scoring
position for the marlins who are looking
for an early lead
up and into jazz chisholm junior
strikeout victim his first time up
and he finds a hole on the left side
that's going to get through into left
field bertie will score easily
and jazz chisholm junior puts the
marlins on top one nothing in the third
and two and two and the runner will take
off and stallings of a sidearm throw
gets them well done
[Applause]
and hernandez gets the strikeout his
third tonight
well hayes base hit his first time two
two pitches swung on and missed strike
three
got him with a slider hayes comes up
empty
reynolds switch hitter batting left one
two is blasted to right
deep toward the wall god home run for
brian reynolds
reynolds for a second time in his career
as homberdog fernandez
that's in the four at bats four home
runs in seven games now for reynolds
yesterday being off and uh monday he'll
be off before the dodgers come in on
tuesday night
brian hayes comes in on to first
halfway mark good ball game 1-1 pirates
and
marlins if your team wasn't winning or
you weren't playing good baseball that
you were going to find your way in
pittsburgh
make things right get things right
that's birdie
perfectly positioned right up the middle
to make the play
on gonzales for the first out ball
balling two strikes to newman
and they fly ball out to right feet for
cooper
makes the catch
he has turned into a number four starter
i think a lot of guys around the game a
lot of teams around the game would love
to have
six strikeouts in his return from the
il1-1
after five
oh two
that's gonna fall in for a base hit
your wish has been granted thank you you
have two left
use them wisely i don't know starling
marte go for two couple of strikeouts
against anderson tonight
fly ball right center field gives it a
ride
and off the top of the wall
hernandez hustling to third another
extra base hit for starling marte
starling martin thought he got all of it
and he didn't miss by much
0-2 pitch coming and a chopper to third
hayes has one play and a run scores
aguilar gets another ribby
and hernandez oh come on is down after
crossing
home plate something pulled on his way
to home he had to hustle the slow roller
to third base and that is a very very
unfortunate set of circumstances for
eleazar who's
finally backing it's a 2-1 marlins lead
here in the sixth
and that is a base hit into right field
so cooper comes through
martin scores and the marlins take a 3-1
lead here in the sixth
here's key brian hayes
hard to right back cooper and looking up
and it's off the wall
another rocket to right field for key
brian hayes
into third with a trip trip triple and
welcome back
another 3-2 pitch and sharply hit it
short a bobble chisholm
recovers throws late pirates within a
run
it's a great at bat by reynolds second
and third
two outs and bounce left side
diving play over at third there's key
brian hayes
he just saved at least a run and now
they're loaded for
stalling line drive to left field this
is gonna get down
jacob stallings the cheetah just doubled
in
one two and three runs
how about that and the bucks lead it now
five to three and a line drive to right
field and there is polanco
and raise the jolly roger what a
comeback
what a comeback